[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
29 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Hey, Francesc.
How you doing today?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very happy.
Very excited about a lot
of Firebase and Firebase
and Firebase today.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It's going to be more Firebase,
and then some more Firebase.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So actually, the
question of the week
and the cool thing of the week
are not related to Firebase.
MARK MANDEL: No.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But-- which
is not all-- not everything's
going to be Firebase,
but we're going
to be talking with a bunch
of people from Firebase.
It's going to be very cool.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
We're going to talk about all
the new stuff they announced
at I/O and all of
that cool stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So if you had the
opportunity to watch
some of the talks on the
Firebase track at Google I/O,
there will be some of the
things that you may know,
but I'm sure there's
going to be things
that you didn't know that are
new and all fresh in Firebase.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Then, at the end,
we're going to be talking about
the question of the week, which
is an interesting one,
which is basically, OK,
so something's going wrong with
my application on Google Cloud
Platform.
How do I figure out
what is going wrong?
So we're going to be talking
a little bit about monitoring,
debugging, and
all the cool stuff
that you never want to
do, but you have to.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So, yeah, that's
going to be fun.
That's going to be at
the end of the episode.
But before that, we're going to
do the cool thing of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So the cool thing of
the week is introducing
on Google Container Engine--
we have now got node pools.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Which
is really cool.
So what that really
means is, you can now
do heterogeneous clusters.
So if you want to have
different types of machines
within your clusters, so
they're not all the same-- maybe
you have some with more
memory, some with more CPU--
you're able to do that and
then have that all exist
within the same
cluster and basically
be able to turn around
and say, like, I
want these containers
to be running
on these sort of
high-mem ones, or I
want these ones to be running
on, say, these high-CPU ones.
And so you can have a little
bit more flexibility in terms
of what sort of
resources you have
available to you in
your GKE cluster.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, and
I think that since once you
have more than two
node pools, well,
more than one node
pool, actually, you're
able to tag those
nodes accordingly.
And then basically
say, I want this
to be running on
some of those nodes
that have the tag high-mem
or whatever you want to do.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Yeah.
No, they actually get
defaultly tagged just
really nice with the
new nodes and like what
they are when you create them.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Perfect.
MARK MANDEL: I actually really
like this cute trick here.
And it's in the blog
post we're talking about.
If you want to do an upgrade
from one version of Kubernetes
to another, the new node
pools have the new version.
So you can actually try
out your stuff on there
before you upgrade the
rest of your other nodes
in your cluster.
So you can do some really
clever things that way, too.
Yeah, it's actually pretty cool.
It's a really nice new feature.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is very cool.
I actually think it's a very
good match for Google Cloud
Spin.
Again, I will keep
on talking about it.
Because it's actually when
you need to extract something
from frame, you need a specific
amount of memory and so on.
But then when you're
stitching stuff together,
you actually need more
CPU rather than anything.
MARK MANDEL: Right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So you
could have different nodes.
That's pretty cool.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
You can be really efficient
with your workload.
So you're only paying for
really the certain stuff
that you need.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
I consider doing
that if I get time.
OK.
So I think it's time to go chat
with our friends from Firebase.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Let's go talk about Firebase.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I'm very
happy to have Abe Haskins
and Doug Stevenson from the
Firebase team here with us
today.
Hi, Abe and Doug.
How are you doing?
ABE HASKINS: Hello.
DOUG STEVENSON: Hey.
Pretty good.
How are you?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
we're going to be chatting
a little bit about
all the new things
that Firebase announced during
Google I/O. But before that,
why don't you tell us a
little bit about yourself.
Why don't we start with you?
DOUG STEVENSON: Yeah.
My name is Doug Stevenson.
I'm a developer advocate
on the Firebase team.
I've been doing Android
for a really long time.
And I specifically work a
lot with the Cloud Test Lab--
actually, now it's called
Firebase Test Lab-- and also
crash reporting.
ABE HASKINS: I'm Abe Haskins.
I'm a Developer Programs
Engineer on the Firebase team.
I've been working
with or for Firebase
for about 3 and 1/2 years now.
I joined when it
was about 10 people
before the database
had security rules.
And I've been watching it grow.
And now I focus mostly
on the Realtime Database,
but I do all sorts of stuff.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So we've had an episode
previously about Firebase.
But if people didn't have
a chance to catch it,
what's the high level?
What is Firebase?
What is this thing?
ABE HASKINS: So
Firebase as a platform
started as the database.
We used to have this
Realtime Database.
We still have it, too.
But we used to have
just this database.
And it was this really cool
way to interact with data
and build real-time
applications.
But as we progressed
with that, it
started to become clear that
we were solving a problem there
but there was a lot of
other problems people had.
They had trouble
authenticating users.
finding a place to put
clients ad applications, HTML,
JavaScript, stuff like that.
So it started becoming
this whole platform.
And today, it's
expanded even more
to be this platform of
things that most people do
that we can make easier,
things that most people need.
So it's just a suite of
tools and different helpers
to speed up development.
MARK MANDEL: And
specifically, what platforms
does Firebase work on?
ABE HASKINS: So we support a
bunch of different platforms.
We have iOS, Android.
We have historically a huge
presence on web, lots and lots
of JavaScript development,
AngularFire, EmberFire.
All of those are
Firebase-specific
integrations for frameworks.
We also have the C++ SDK
that is in development.
I believe it's a beta label
now, but I'm not quite sure.
But that's also out there.
MARK MANDEL: Also you've
got Unity integrations too,
don't you?
ABE HASKINS: We do have a
Unity integration, which is
a wrap around our native SDK.
So all the awesomeness of
those come right into Unity.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So there's a little bit of
the history of Firebase.
What about the new
Firebase that we all
heard about during Google I/0?
What are the new things that
everybody should know about?
DOUG STEVENSON: Well, there's
a bunch of new things.
So like Abe said, we
have Realtime Database,
which is still the
Realtime Database
that you know and love.
There are 15 total components.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Not bad.
DOUG STEVENSON: 13 of
which were core Firebase
and two which we're
calling integrations, which
are like standalone products,
which just work well
with Firebase.
So I'm going to try to remember
as many of them as I can.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I actually
have the list of the 15
components in front of
me, and you don't see it,
so please go for it.
DOUG STEVENSON: This is a quiz.
All right.
So let's see.
We have--
MARK MANDEL: Don't get
anything wrong now.
DOUG STEVENSON: Let's see.
We have Realtime Database.
We have Storage.
We have Hosting.
We have Authentication,
Remote Config.
There's Test Lab for Android,
Crash Reporting, Dynamic Links.
Oh, I'm breaking down here.
App Indexing.
ABE HASKINS: App Indexing.
DOUG STEVENSON: Invites.
MARK MANDEL: Invites.
DOUG STEVENSON: OK,
I'm going to have--
ABE HASKINS: And the rest.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Rest stuff?
I'm going to help
you a little bit.
the integrations are AdMob and--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
ABE HASKINS: Adwords.
DOUG STEVENSON: Adwords, yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Adwords.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
there's also Notifications
and you missed--
DAN STEVENSON:
And Cloud Messing.
ABE HASKINS: And the big one.
DAN STEVENSON: Yes.
ABE HASKINS: You
missed Cloud Messaging.
DAN STEVENSON: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And also something
that-- the one that you
missed I think it's Analytics.
ABE HASKINS: Yeah.
DAN STEVENSON: Oh, yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's Analytics.
DOUG STEVENSON: That's
actually a really big one,
because that supports a lot
of the other components,
and all tightly very
integrated with Analytics.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, so could
you tell us a little bit more
about Analytics itself?
DOUG STEVENSON:
Yeah, well it's--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
What does it do?
What it does?
Analyzes?
DOUG STEVENSON: Yeah, so
it's an all new analyst
component that is made
for mobile devices,
so it's Android and iOS.
It will collect and report
a lot of information
about how users are using
your app automatically,
so you don't have
to write anything.
But you can track your
own events on top of that.
So you have a quota
of 500 custom events
that you can log and
parameterize yourself.
And once you start to
collect all that information,
you can then turn those
events and user properties
into audiences--
actually audiences
you can define
based off of events
that have happened for a user.
So you can say, everyone
who's launched my app
and gotten to, say,
level 3 in a game,
you can create an
audience just for that.
You can also use the
audiences for notifications.
Let's see, what else can you do?
You can also do funnel
analysis, and you
can export your data to
BigQuery for querying ad hoc.
MARK MANDEL: Now I
believe this is free?
DOUG STEVENSON: It is
free, and it's unlimited.
It's kind of hard to think
about it like that, you know,
there's so much data
going into the system.
MARK MANDEL: Say
it one more time
because there's a number of
people who when they hear free,
don't believe it.
So is it free?
DOUG STEVENSON: OK, it's
free as in F-R-E-E, like--
MARK MANDEL: As in beer.
DAN STEVENSON: As in beer.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
unlimited for real.
DOUG STEVENSON: Unlimited,
so you can send as much data
into it as you want.
Now--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is an amazing.
DOUG STEVENSON: --And Crash
Reporting is like that too.
Crash Reporting is also
free and unlimited,
but it's worth
noting as a caveat,
you can't just jam
as much data as you--
you can't just spin up as
much data as you possibly can.
There is reasonable
usage patterns
which we can reasonably
handle, you know,
you can't force
anything beyond that.
ABE HASKINS: There's
abuse vectors in place,
but for all practical uses,
it is free and unlimited.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
That is very impressive.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
what's sort of use cases
do you think you're going to
see people using Analytics for?
Have you seen anything already?
ABE HASKINS: I mean,
you can imagine
that this is Google's version
of Google Analytics for Mobile,
and you can-- we have
more than a decade
of people doing crazy things
with Google Analytics,
and we expect fully to
see all of those times 100
with Firebase Analytics.
The amount of flexibility we
introduce with these custom
events and the ability to
do all these funnelings
and notifications
and things like
that, it's just-- it's huge,
and it's very open-ended.
I haven't seen
anything specifically
that sticks out because
it's still very early,
but I'm sure we're going to see
tons and tons of crazy things.
Plus, it's free, and
that always brings up
people who build
crazy stuff on things.
DOUG STEVENSON: Yeah, one of
the things that people really
want to do is they
want to identify
who their big spenders
are so there's a concept
of lifetime value of a user.
Then you can, again,
use that to target them
with, say, notifications,
or put them in A/B testing
with Remote Config based on
their prior behavior, which
is huge for a lot of apps.
MARK MANDEL: That
actually segues just
into what I wanted
to talk about.
Do you want to talk a little
about Remote Config and what
that is, and how that works?
DOUG STEVENSON: Yeah,
so Remote Config--
you can basically think of it as
like a switchboard in the sky,
right?
So you can-- I know
it's kind of a goofy way
of thinking about it.
MARK MANDEL: Trying to
imagine that right now.
DOUG STEVENSON: So what
you can do-- I mean,
there's a few things
you can do with it.
I think the most popular
thing is A/B testing.
So you can have two different
experiences in your app.
And you want to pit
them against each other
to see which one
makes more money,
or which one has higher
retention, or has better,
you know, play
through for a game.
So you can run that test,
you can define percentages.
You could say
50/50 of people get
one experience over
the other, and then
measure the outcome
in Analytics.
The other thing
that people can do
is, say, roll out a
new feature instantly.
So a prior problem that
app developers had is they
had to submit to the
store, and then the store
doesn't give you a guarantee
about how long that, you know,
the new feature gets out.
Both Android and iOS
have this problem.
But with Remote
Config, what you do
is you code up your feature
early, publish it ahead
of time, then when you're
confident that the app is
actually on the
user's devices, you
can use Remote Config
to flip a switch
and then everyone gets the new
experience of the new feature
instantly.
So you can time that with,
like, a television event,
or a tweet, or
something like that,
to make sure that everyone
gets the experience at the time
that you want them to have it.
ABE HASKINS: Yeah, and
it's not just flipping
switches that you
manually go in and set.
You can do that where you say,
I'm going to change this value,
and then users get some
different experience.
But you can do things where you
say people located in Australia
are going to get a different
home page than people located
in the US.
People running an older
version of Android
might get a warning saying
you need to upgrade.
Otherwise, we're not
going to support this.
There's a bunch of these
different categories
and buckets that
you can filter on,
so just arbitrary percentage
for A/B testing, that's there.
But we have a whole
bunch of different ways
to send different values
to different people.
DOUG STEVENSON: Yeah, the
other thing you can do
is have your strings in your
app defined in Remote Config.
So you can say in different
parts of the world,
change the experience.
Like, for Android, I'm
an Android developer,
so you can put
that in resources,
but you can't-- once you've
baked in those resources
into the app, they're
there forever, right?
With Remote Config,
now you can make
those say whatever
you want, at the time
that you want, in the part
of the world that you want.
MARK MANDEL: I was
going say this sounds
particular powerful.
You're talking
about sort of being
able to build your own
audiences within site analytics,
like say, people have gone
past level 3, or something
like that, and then being able
to combine that with Remote
Config as well or being
able to say, like,
these particular
audiences are going
to see this particular thing,
which is different from people
who, say, have just
started, or are
less experienced in
the game, or whatever
application you've got.
That sounds like
really cool stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
I have a question.
So if I understand correctly,
the main difference
between using-- so
if you want to store
some configuration that
might change over time,
you have the option
between storing it
in the Realtime
Database directly,
or store it in Remote Config.
What is the big difference
between doing one or the other?
ABE HASKINS: I think there's
a handful of differences.
The Realtime Database is
designed for small amounts
of quickly changing data.
That's always been the focus
of the Realtime Database.
So if you have huge strings
that have descriptions
in different
languages, you could
put those in the Realtime
Database, that would be fine.
But if you're going and
you're filtering them
based on language or
something, otherwise,
like once they
get to the device,
you might as well do
that in a system that
serves that up automatically.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
ABE HASKINS: There's few
things that you couldn't
do if you wanted to jam
into the Realtime Database
and then do this
filtering on your own,
but it makes more
sense and the interface
is better for this
type of thing.
It also connects
better to Analytics
than just Realtime Database was.
You'd have to be sending
your own events to say
people are doing this and that.
But Remote Config
just ties right in.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
DOUG STEVENSON: I think
the other thing to note
is that Realtime Database is
good for storing model data,
whereas Remote Config
is better for just
sort of like, regular
key value pairs.
And you also get
like a nice dashboard
to make the changes in that,
whereas with Database, you
have to go into
the database viewer
and drill down into
the item that you want
to change and then change it,
and it doesn't feel as right,
you know.
ABE HASKINS: And I think that's
an interesting discussion
with the new Firebase
feature that we announced
at I/O. Some of them
are targeted for more
technical people, like the
Database or Authentication,
some are targeted at more
marketers or different business
level folks.
And I think Remote Config
is walking that line, where
if I give you access
to the database,
and you're my boss's
boss, and you know nothing
about our database
structure, there's
a really good chance you're
going to break something.
But if I give you
access to Remote Config
and there's only a
few different ways
you can set things,
and configure audiences
and whatnot, that's
a marketing problem.
You guys can play with
that and get that right,
and I'll deal with all the
technical structured things
that if you break you're going
to actually take stuff down,
or what have you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I see.
So since you mentioned
it, could you
talk a little bit
of Authentication?
Because that's actually probably
my second favorite feature
of Firebase.
The first one is clearly the
Database, but Authentication,
the fact that I don't have to
manage OAuth 2.0 on my site,
that is amazing.
Could you tell us a little
bit more about that?
ABE HASKINS: Yeah, so have
you have you guys ever used
like OAuth to set up,
like, Twitter login,
or Facebook login?
MARK MANDEL: I've
tried very hard not to.
ABE HASKINS: Yeah, exactly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I've
done it a couple of times.
ABE HASKINS: I think most
people have had about nine times
of trying not to, and then
one time of, like, succeeding,
but really hating
themselves for it.
The Firebase
Authentication is just
an attempt to make that the
experience it should be.
In that you, as a
developer, if you just
want to sign in
with Twitter, you
shouldn't have to be
running your own servers.
You shouldn't have to deal
with these complicated OAuth
handshakes that have, like,
three or four steps in them.
You should be able to
say, sign in with Twitter,
and then have the application
pop out to the Twitter app,
do whatever it has to do
to get that authentication
flow complete and get
that back to your app.
And that's what Firebase
Authentication does.
In most cases, it's
a couple of lines
to do with this authentication.
In the web version, it's one
line to pop up an OAuth window.
We dramatically
simplify the flow
of integrating with third
party providers, specifically
GitHub, Facebook, Google, and--
DOUG STEVENSON: Twitter.
ABE HASKINS: Twitter, yes.
Yeah.
And with that authentication,
we also offer,
if you don't like
those providers,
the ability to generate
your own tokens
and tie into your
existing authentication
back ends if you have them.
DOUG STEVENSON: And I do
love the new feature now
that you can do Federated
Auth, so that if people
want to log in with separate
accounts for different OAuth
providers, you now provide the
hook so that you can just join
those together really nicely.
ABE HASKINS: That's
been heavily requested.
That's definitely on
the sheet of things that
have been said so many times.
We're working on it,
we're working on it.
And I don't think people
believed us anymore.
And then we came
out with it, so.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So there are also
several new features
you have that you've
kind of absorbed
into Firebase from externally.
Cloud Messaging comes to
mind as well as Test Lab.
Do you want to talk
about those two as well,
and how they got pulled
in, and like, are there
differences now, are they
the same, what changed there?
ABE HASKINS: I
think I can probably
speak about Cloud
Messaging, and then Doug
knows much more about
Test Lab than I do.
Cloud Messaging, Firebase Cloud
Messaging, or Google Cloud
Messaging, serve
the same purpose.
Like you said, we kind
of absorbed it in,
but we made it more
Firebasey at the same time.
MARK MANDEL: I want to
know what that means.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Firebasey.
ABE HASKINS: Yeah, what that
means from our perspective
is we made it easier to use,
we made it integrate better
with the rest of
our suite of tools.
It's not just a GCM
with a letter changed.
We went through and we
rethought a bunch of the APIs,
and we thought, all right.
We have this existing Firebase
SDK you're already importing.
How much of this
can we do for you?
How can we simplify this?
How can we make a tie into
your Analytics and Firebase
Notifications?
So we improved it in that way.
It's much easier to get up and
running with than GCM ever was.
MARK MANDEL: So take it
a back a step for a sec.
What exactly was
Google Cloud Messaging?
Like, what does it do for
people, in case people haven't
seen that before?
ABE HASKINS: So
Cloud Messaging is
a way of sending push
notifications to devices.
So some of those pop
up and make noises--
MARK MANDEL: That
was great timing.
ABE HASKINS: Yeah, so
some of those you pop up
and you see, it
might say, hey, you
should come beat
level 3 of this game.
Some of them happen behind
the scenes and trigger things
in your app, but it's
basically just a way
of pushing notifications
to devices.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
So as you were
saying, like now it's
a lot easier to use,
and a lot better, and--
ABE HASKINS: Yeah, exactly.
MARK MANDEL: --cleaner.
ABE HASKINS: Yeah, it's never
been a horribly difficult thing
to use, but wherever we could
when we rolled products in,
we improved the APIs,
improved the experience,
and integrated them as
well as we possibly could.
DOUG STEVENSON:
And that's related
to Notifications too, which
is now a different product.
ABE HASKINS: So,
yeah, this probably
requires saying very
explicitly, there's
been confusion around Firebase
Cloud Messaging versus Firebase
Notifications.
And this is fair.
It's a little confusing, which
is which, and how they relate.
But you can think of Firebase
Cloud Messaging as the API,
the SDK, that's on your
phone, that you send down
to your clients that lets
you receive messages.
You can also programmatically
send messages
through FCM from your existing
server if you wanted to.
Now FCM goes back to that split.
I mean, sorry, not FCM.
The Notification
concept goes back
to that split I was talking
about between Firebase products
for technical folks, and
Firebase products for more
marketing business folks.
So if you have
audiences set up, if you
have your analytics configured,
or different groups you want
to filter and send
notifications to,
historically, you'd have
to use a third party tool.
You'd have to go and rely
on your analytics platform
to give you the ability to send
notifications to these people.
That's what cloud-- what
Firebase Notifications does
for you.
It's a nice interface, it's
a UI for non-technical folks
to go in and say, I want
to target this group,
I want to send messages
to these people,
people who speak these
languages get this notification,
or whatever.
MARK MANDEL: So
Messaging is more
for the technical
programmatic people,
whereas the Notification
stuff's probably
more for the less technical.
ABE HASKINS: Yeah, exactly.
DOUG STEVENSON: An important
distinguishing factor
between them is
Firebase Cloud Messaging
is more for like
event driven messages,
so you have something that--
like a notification that
happens in response to
something else that happened
in your system,
whereas Notifications
is more like not user
to user, but, you know,
app manager to user.
Like, I want to type a
message in the console
and send it to my user
so they can see it.
So that's that case.
ABE HASKINS: Yeah, and
they both come back to FCM.
Like, you're never going
to import the Firebase
Notifications into your SDK.
Once you put Firebase
Cloud Messaging in there,
you have the ability to use
Notifications to send messages
down to your devices.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
And Test Lab.
DOUG STEVENSON: Yeah,
so it's formally
called Firebase
Test Lab for Android
because it only supports
Android devices right now.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
DOUG STEVENSON: But this is
basically the same Cloud Test
Lab product that's been
moved over into Firebase,
so now you can do the same
things you could before.
So there's a robo test, which
is like a fully automated test
that we have this software
agent that basically
works your app for you.
It sort of discovers
UI widgets and buttons,
and pokes and prods, and
sort of systematically
crawls your app to find
all the features, which
is pretty cool because you
don't write a line of code
to do that.
You get that-- you get
something kind of for nothing.
Which is great, because if
you don't want to write tests,
and-- I know I don't
want to write tests.
Tests are not exactly
like fun to write.
MARK MANDEL: I
like writing tests.
I really enjoy writing tests.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You also
like writing Haskell.
DOUG STEVENSON: So
for people like you
who enjoy writing tests,
if you enjoy writing tests,
you can do that.
You can write Android
instrumentation tests as well,
and execute that
against your app.
So you can upload both
APKs, your app APK
and your instrumentation test,
and we'll run those as well.
Let's see, what else
can we do with Test Lab?
There's--
MARK MANDEL: I'm
guessing you can
run across various different
devices as well in sizes--
DOUG STEVENSON: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: --And
shapes and stuff?
DOUG STEVENSON: Yeah, so that's
what we call the device test
matrix, so what you
do is you select
the devices, the actual
models of devices
that you're
interested in testing.
You select the API levels,
the Android API levels.
Not every device
supports every API level,
but we'll find an intersecting
combination that will fit.
You can test in portrait,
you can test in landscape,
and so based on your
selections, we'll
create a series of
tests that actually
satisfies your requirements.
MARK MANDEL: That's cool.
And do these run
on real devices,
or is it all emulated,
or, how does that work?
DOUG STEVENSON: Yeah, so
these are actually devices
sitting in a rack in the Cloud.
You could think of it like
Cloud hosted or managed devices.
So you don't ever have
to touch a device.
You don't have to have tangled
cables on your computer.
Back when I did testing as
a startup a long time ago,
it was like you had
this stack of devices,
you were constantly like, let's
do this one now, let's try
this one, let's try this one.
And I only have
one USB port, and I
can't manage the whole thing.
So now, you don't
have to do that.
You can run all--
you're basically
delegating all of your
tests into the Cloud
and then we'll send you test
results when they're ready.
And they're running in
parallel, so for as many devices
as you've selected, we
will try to use them
as fast as we possibly can.
MARK MANDEL: And did
this platform change
as it got absorbed by
Firebase, or is it still fairly
much the same, or--
DOUG STEVENSON: The platform
itself is mostly the same.
The big change was that we had
a UI Cloud Developer Platform
Console.
Now that's been moved
over into Firebase.
So now, you see Test Lab along
with all your other products.
I think the UI is better,
it's little easier to use,
but for the most part, the
infrastructure is the same.
Now there is one new thing
that goes along with this.
It's not part of
Test Lab proper,
it's actually part
of Android Studio,
and this is coming with
Android Studio 2.2.
It is this product
called Cassette.
And what it lets you do is
launch your app on a device,
then you use it, you actually
type in, push the buttons,
enter the data for the
test the way you want to,
and then what it will do is
record everything you've done
and create Espresso
tests for you.
So you don't actually have to
write out all of the on view,
click this button, then that
thing, and check that text,
it's all done in a UI,
which is super handy.
You can grind through
a lot of test cases
very quickly that way.
MARK MANDEL: You say
it was called Cassette?
DOUG STEVENSON: Cassette, yes.
MARK MANDEL: As in,
like, what I used
to listen to music on
when I was a teenager?
DOUG STEVENSON: Yes, oh,
I used to save my programs
on when I was a kid.
Yes, I am that old.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Wow, people are old.
Cool.
We're pretty much
running out of time.
But there was something that
I wanted to discuss, too,
was Storage, and how is it
different to Google Cloud
Storage, if any
difference exists?
ABE HASKINS: So it is
different in the way
you interact with it.
Firebase Storage is backed
by Google Cloud Storage.
When you sign up
for Firebase, you
get a Firebase-- I mean, a
Google Cloud bucket that you
can interact with.
You can even open it
in the Cloud console.
And if you have
existing apps that
use existing APIs to interact
with the Google Cloud bucket,
you can interact with
it from your Firebase.
I mean, your Firebase
bucket can be
interacted within the same way.
The benefit of using Firebase
Storage over Cloud Storage
is that Firebase
Storage is designed
to be used from clients.
Google Cloud Storage never
really had a good solution
to I have a user, I
want to upload an image,
I want to upload directly to
that bucket from my web page
or from my app.
You'd have to bounce it
through your own server.
You'd have to do checks on the
file type and the file size
and things like that.
And eventually, you could get
in the Cloud Storage bucket,
but it was kind of wonky.
Firebase Storage introduces
two really cool concepts.
One is the client side SDK for
doing these types of uploads
so you can just say, hey,
upload this securely and safely
directly to my Firebase Storage
and the underlying Google Cloud
Storage bucket.
And the other is
the security rules
that allow you to say, OK,
this person can only upload
to this path inside my bucket.
They can only overwrite
their own profile image,
they can only be-- I don't
know if this is out currently,
or if we're working on
this now, but the ability
to restrict file sizes, image
sizes, things like that.
So you can say a profile
image can only be
this big or things like that.
So there's a lot of
benefits in that,
like I said before, these
are things you could do.
They're like Authentication.
You could do the
OAuth flow, or you
could do this and save
yourself a bunch of time.
Same with this.
Using just Google
Cloud Storage, you
could have sent everything
through your own server, gotten
to the same point, but we
just save you a ton of time.
DOUG STEVENSON: Now those
Authentication rules.
Those are just like very similar
to, if not exactly the same,
as Firebase Realtime Database.
ABE HASKINS: Yeah, so
they're definitely similar.
They're not the same syntax.
They are specifically
used for storage,
like, there's very different
requirements for the storage
rules versus the
Firebase security rules.
But if you've ever written
database security rules,
you'll feel very at home
using this very descriptive,
nicely typed thing, to
say, oh, this location,
I'm logged in as this user,
I can write here, I can't.
It's very, very sane, and
you have all your rules
in one place, so
it's easy to look at.
In the same way, they're
the same benefits
you get from the
database security rules.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah I
know when I used it
for my presentation
I gave at I/O,
and it feels like
interacting with Storage
is almost very similar to
interacting with the Realtime
Database.
You end up with the
same instructions,
and it's super nice to use,
and probably one of the nicest
ways I've ever used an
interaction with the Google
Cloud Storage.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So in the same way
that if something in
the database changes,
you can watch that change
and receive a notification,
can you do the same
thing for storage?
ABE HASKINS: Not really.
What you can do is you can
say, I'm going to upload this,
and then you'll have a location
in the Realtime Database,
and when your upload is
complete, you flip a switch,
say, oh there's a new version
and everyone can update.
So we don't have the ability to
do that type of updating today.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
Because that's
something, yeah, I
could have them-- I was
thinking about that.
DOUG STEVENSON: There's one cool
thing you can do with Storage.
So on the client
SDK side, you can
do-- you can kick off
an upload, and if it's
going to take a long time,
or if you lose connectivity,
it will automatically
resume it because it's
meant for large
files, it's meant
for user generated content.
So if users are taking
a bunch of photos
and you want to upload
them all, we don't have to,
like, sit there and
make them wait for it.
You can go into the background,
complete in the background,
and be sure that if they go to
a tunnel, lose connectivity,
that's fine, we'll restart.
But it's also fully
secure, so everything's
over secure connection.
ABE HASKINS: Yeah,
the Firebase Storage
is definitely the
product that just
feels like classic
Firebase I think the most.
It's built with
things like that,
like that resilience that
the Realtime Database had
was always a focus.
The ability-- you can go
through a tunnel and your app
keeps working.
Storage we wanted to be the
same way, and it very much is.
It goes back to the thing, like,
you could do that yourself,
but it would be a pain.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, absolutely.
OK, we're definitely
running out of time now,
but is there anything
that you want
to mention that
hasn't been mentioned,
or something you want to
highlight a particular feature
that you think is a
really impressive,
or anything in
those sort of lines?
DOUG STEVENSON: I think the
whole platform is impressive.
I'm serious.
And I'm not saying this just
because I spoke on this topic
at I/O.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
[INAUDIBLE] our advocate.
DOUG STEVENSON: Yeah.
Yeah, I'm paid to say this.
No, but it really
is very impressive.
When you look at
all the components
and how they work really
well together, I look at it,
and I'm like, as an Android
developer going back
into, like, 2009,
I had none of this,
and now there's all this stuff.
And so I'm kind of jealous.
Like if I had then
what I had now,
it'd be a completely
different thing.
So I'm a little jealous
of all the people
who are starting up new
projects who have this platform
to build on top.
They're just going to have
such great a suite of tools,
and you know, I really want to
see what people build with it.
ABE HASKINS: It's
absolutely crazy
what we were able to launch,
and just how much I would like
to be out there using this.
It's just such a
great suite of tools,
and you can see in so
many places it was just
built by people who were
passionate and wanted
to help people.
And after I/O, we did this
big launch and everyone
was I think expected to
take time off and go relax.
It was a week after
I/O, and people
were still putting in
these crazy long hours,
still working on stuff, not
because things were breaking--
the launch went fantastically--
but because they
were obsessed with
building something awesome.
And I think it shows
in the product.
I think it absolutely does.
That passion comes through,
and this is just the beginning.
I'm excited for the future.
It's going to be good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
I think that that
sentence is a great way
to finish the interview.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
That was great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you so much.
DAN STEVENSON: Well,
thanks for having us.
ABE HASKINS: [INAUDIBLE]
MARK MANDEL: It was good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you very much
to Abe and Doug for joining us
today.
That was a super interesting
conversation about Firebase.
I'm particularly excited
about all the new features,
I think they're
going to be great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah
I'm very, very excited.
I saw a lot of
people at Google I/O
that were very surprised
with the huge push
that Firebase got.
All the new features.
I'm very excited
about using them, too.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it's super
nice to see the investment
that Google is
putting into them.
It's really, I think it's
really going to pay off.
Excellent.
So you wanted to
have a little chat
about how do we debug stuff.
That's a very broad statement.
What do you mean there?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It is
a very broad statement,
but basically the question
was something around, OK,
so something's wrong
with my application
and I'm not very
sure what it is.
What are my options?
What do I do?
MARK MANDEL: OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
basically, the answer
could be something like,
well, write more unit tests.
Right?
But the problem is that
what if what is going wrong
it's only going
wrong in production?
MARK MANDEL: That happens.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That happens.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sadly
happens very often,
that it works on my machine.
It's not a thing, really.
So what I wanted to--
basically, the answer
I wanted to give
to this was there's
a lot of different
things that you
can do to basically
investigate what
is a problem in
application and production.
And most of them are
actually under these features
that we call Stackdriver.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
Stackdriver has a bunch
of things that you can do.
One of them, the
first one is-- OK,
so if something is
going wrong, there's
two different kinds of wrong.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I was going
to say, like, what does wrong
mean, right?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So,
one of the wrongs
is you were actually
getting errors.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And in that case,
you're going to see
that Stackdriver
has a way of monitoring
those errors--
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --and
putting them together
according to some template.
So you can actually
get that, hey,
during the last
hour, 500 occurrences
of these specific
kind of error happen.
You can create alerts
on that, and get
alerted when those errors
go higher than some--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --threshold.
So it's very useful.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, Stackdriver
Error Reporting is quite nice.
You can also do stuff like,
oh, this error just happens,
and it doesn't
matter if it does.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
it's just like shut up.
Yeah.
Basically.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, but
otherwise, like, yeah,
this one's actually
really important
and we need to get people out
of bed for this particular one.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: We need that
sort of error reporting.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
then when that happens,
something that you
may consider is
like, well, I'm just
going to go there
and maybe you have
like a Java application
and I'm just going to
read the exception stack.
Stack?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Yeah, you're good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I don't know.
I don't do exceptions, so
I'll remember the name.
So yeah, you can check
the exception stack
and understand [INAUDIBLE]
what's going on,
but that's sometimes not enough.
And in that case, there's
this really cool thing.
It's basically a
debugger in production.
A debugger in production
sounds like an awful idea,
because putting break
points on your production
is something that you should
never even consider doing it.
Please, don't do that at home.
But what we have rather
than break points,
we have snapshot points.
So what you say is
like, hey, I want
to know what are the values
of all the [INAUDIBLE]
stack, and the local
fireballs, and all that stuff.
MARK MANDEL: At this snapshot,
this particular point in time.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And you
can even add conditions.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It was
like, when x equals 10,
give me all the
values of the stuff.
And then with that,
basically, you'll
be able to kind of
debug in production,
but without the cost
of actually stopping
any jobs in production,
which is a really bad idea.
MARK MANDEL: I'll actually put
a little thing on here as well.
It's super, super, super alpha.
But there is a plug-in for
Google Cloud Platform IntelliJ,
and the integrated
debugging stuff
they've got for
Java applications
in that is very, very slick.
Worth looking at, probably
not worth trying just yet,
but worth keeping an eye on.
It's super interesting.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
And yeah, on top
of that, you also
get the other kind of
wrong, which is things
are just working
but just very slow.
And then in that case, you
have the performance insights
and analytics, so
you're going to be
able to see what are
all the calls generated
from your request.
So imagine that
you get a request
and rather than sending one
datastore read operation,
you send 1,000.
Maybe there's something
wrong in there.
Maybe you send those
1,000s one after the other.
So concurrency, my friend.
Those things are
something that you
can see very easily with
the detail from insights
and the analytics that
Stackdriver provides.
MARK MANDEL: Yes,
Stackdriver Trace
is also really cool in that
it can give you alerts when
performance starts to degrade.
It's not just a
reactionary thing
from users sending you stuff.
If you start to see that
performance is happening,
you can set up alerts, and say
if performance on this website
drops below a certain threshold,
or something like that,
then you can be
like, hey, maybe you
do need to get someone up
in the middle of the night,
or at least send an
e-mail, or do something.
Super, super useful.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And there's
actually a very good talk
that if you're
interested on this topic,
you should definitely
check it out.
We're going to have the link
on the show notes as usual.
And it's called, "Diagnostics,
spend less time diagnosing,
and more time developing."
MARK MANDEL: I'll make one
mention of one extra product,
because I think
it's worth noting.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sure.
MARK MANDEL: It's the
Stackdriver Logging.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: True.
MARK MANDEL: Super basic, right?
But it is a central
place to send your logs.
Like, for a lot of our
platform and servers stuff, so
app engine, et cetera,
that's just built in.
Like, if I want to go see all
my logs, or my community apps,
or anything like that, I
can just go right there.
But I can also send out custom
logs, there's API calls,
I can do what
[INTERPOSING VOICES],
I can do it a whole
bunch of different ways.
And so, you know, log
your applications.
So if you really
want to see what's
going on inside your
app, just good old
classic text-based
logs, sometimes
that just does the trick.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
something that just helps.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool, so
I think it's time to let us
know what are you
going to be doing?
Where are you right now?
Like, let's travel
into the future.
MARK MANDEL: Into the future.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Say it's Wednesday.
MARK MANDEL: So right now,
I will be in Minneapolis.
I'll be between two events.
So tomorrow, I will be
at Open Source North.
After that, I will
be at Dev Objective,
and then, yeah,
later in the month
I'll be in New York for
another event, which I still
haven't got the details for.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Soon.
One day.
MARK MANDEL: Soon, one day.
One day, that will come through.
And yourself?
Where will you be?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So right now,
if I've been lucky enough not
to crash my bike yet--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
don't do that.
Please don't do that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
No, I'll try not to.
I'll be somewhere
right around half way
from San Francisco to Los
Angeles, maybe in Pismo Beach,
eating some cinnamon rolls.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, very nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, that's my hope.
MARK MANDEL: Really?
Cinnamon rolls in the middle
of a massive bike ride?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Exactly.
MARK MANDEL: OK, fair enough.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I will
not feel guilty for that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
you know what?
That's fair.
That's totally fair.
I totally-- that sounds
totally reasonable.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, but
while I'm away, some of you
miss my voice.
I wanted to mention also, I
just released a screencast
of basically all the gold
tooling that I used in today.
And it's like 40 minutes,
which is pretty long,
but I think it's
going to be fun.
There is a bit music in the
middle to make it more--
MARK MANDEL: It's
really cute music.
I have to admit.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
so I'll add a link
to the show in that series so
you can check it out and let
me know what you think.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I know
we haven't mentioned it
in a while,
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: If people want
to get in contact with us--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Let's see if I'm
able to remember all of this.
MARK MANDEL: So if people
want to reach us on email?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Campo-- no.
MARK MANDEL: That's
your email address.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I was
going to say my email.
GCPpodcast-- No.
Hello@gdppodcast.com.
MARK MANDEL: There we go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There you go.
MARK MANDEL: So
hello@gcppodcast.com.
If they want to
reach us on Reddit?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's
slash-- no, /r/GCPpodcast.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, they
want to reach us on Twitter?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
GCPpodcast, @GCPpodcast.
MARK MANDEL: There we go.
If they want to
reach us on Google+?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: +GCPpodcast?
MARK MANDEL: Nailed it.
And we also have the
Slack channel hash podcast
in the GCP community--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Indeed.
MARK MANDEL: As well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And I feel
like I'm forgetting something.
MARK MANDEL: I don't think so.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: No?
OK, well, that's--
MARK MANDEL: That's--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
--pretty much it.
MARK MANDEL: --pretty
much all the evidence.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Oh, the web page.
GCPpodcast.com.
MARK MANDEL: That's true.
Yeah, that's got
everything on it
as well, in case you need
any of those resources.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
Well, thank you so
much again this week
for joining me on this
amazing episode, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, and thank
you so much for joining me.
Good luck with your
biking next week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
And talk to you next week.
MARK MANDEL: See you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]